why now Todd why take on Trump now well
I think with immigration reform in the
news and with a lot of false information
out there we thought it's a great time
to remind people of the incredible role
that immigrants play and why we need to
fix our broken immigration reform system
and that means sensible security
provisions it means having an
immigration system that works for
today's economy and it needs to the 11
million undocumented immigrants are here
giving them the ability to go through a
background check and come out and get
legal status in a pathway to citizenship
and you know the time to do that is now
okay so you've said Trump and Scott
Walker don't have the best stance on
immigration but what candidates do you
like who's doing it right well let me
pause when I say when you say they don't
have the best stance let's say exactly
what what it is when you talk about
rounding up and forcibly deported 12
million people you know that's creating
a police state that's costing according
to a political our conservative think
tank six hundred billion dollars you
know that's not just not being good on
immigration reform that's against
American value so I think it's really
important to put a pin in that and say
you know this isn't about arguing at the
margins here this is to say we believe
that we're not going to go and do this
horrible thing that's being proposed ok
so what candidates do you like who's
closest to what you want well I think
there's a number of candidates on both
sides of the aisle who on this basic
question that I want to talk about today
which is you know are we really going to
round up and you know 11 million people
are we going to say that we think we
should radically restrict the ability of
the United States to have the best and
the brightest come here if you look at
both sides of the aisle you know you'll
see people who are doing great in the
polls people aren't doing is great in
the polls who are in favor of that but
this baseline question here is I think a
really important one and you see that on
the Democratic side somebody like
Secretary Clinton you look on the
Republican side you see someone like
Lindsey Graham you look at somebody like
governor Bush you know these are people
who are all willing to say the obvious
to us which is the idea that we're going
to round up these people is just plain
wrong okay quickly Todd how involved is
Mark Zuckerberg at this point how often
does he check in with you what does he
want
well mark is one of obviously one of our
really high profound errs he's really
passionate about this issue you know
what I'm really excited about it for it
is you know we actually just crossed
over having four hundred and five
thousand different people speak out in
favor of immigration reform to contact
their member of Congress in support of
immigration reform you know every day we
don't pass immigration reform cost our
economy 37 million dollars it's it's
hurting the technology industry it's
hurting families and so every day we go
along is just where we're getting
stronger